Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn.
It's the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
June 5th,
the first Monday of the fuck in here.
I gave you an extra one that was for all the January,
sort of held the note.
Didn't like that.
I got fuck yourself,
whatever.
Another year.
Another year is started.
I gotta be honest with you.
It's still Sunday and I'm watching the tail end of the Dallas Detroit game.
I already know who wins.
There's only a minute 29 left.
And uh,
I was watching the game and real time and a Dallas score to go up 24 to 20.
So I ran upstairs to cut myself a little piece of apple pie,
like the fat fuck that I'm becoming quickly.
And uh,
I was in such a rush.
I took the fucking,
sorry for the echo.
Uh,
I'm downstairs and uh,
we don't have any enough furniture.
What do you want from me?
Okay.
It's a goal of mine at some point
in 2015 and once I'm done paying for all the fucking horse shit that I had done
down here,
once they get that out of the way,
maybe I can afford a fucking chair.
So anyways,
so I run up there.
All right.
Like a typical football Finn.
Okay.
Half a run,
half a wattle breathing through my mouth after three stairs.
Okay.
After I had the audacity to scream at the fucking TV,
you know?
Right.
Can't even run up 10 fucking stairs.
When did you know
first two steps?
I'm running like a 12 second 40 by the time I get to the fifth step,
I'm running like a 62nd 40 is just going downhill.
So get up there,
chop myself out a piece of Pie and I didn't even do that.
I took the lid off the thing,
the glass lid thing that our neighbors got us as a a house warming gift and I
wasn't even looking and I said it half on the counter,
half into air and it just shattered all over the place.
I got to tell you it sweeping it up.
I could tell how expensive it was.
You know,
people can tell you that something made out of glass is expensive,
but you don't realize how expensive it is until you break it and you're sweeping
it up and you feel that weight and the dust pan like that.
That was some quality glass.
So I already know that the cowboys hang on to win this fucking game because a
buddy of mine,
Keith texted me and I'm what kills me,
the lovely Nia walking through.
Um,
and what kills me is,
uh,
is all it takes is one person to walk in the room.
I completely lose my train of thought.
That's what kills me.
Now what the fuck kills me.
The fuck was I just talking about
Nia is this,
is this another add thing?
What?
Ah,
shut up easy as B a l l l B you are fucking Douche bag.
Why was he talking about God damn.
What the fuck was I talking to me?
I don't walk in the room when I'm doing the podcast.
All right.
No I fucking I was,
I was,
I was going good there.
Oh Jesus.
All right.
Anyways cause it's the shredder retrace our steps.
I'm a winded fat guy and running up the stairs.
Cowboys a romp.
I break the lid.
This is some quality glass.
I go to fucking sweep it up and I ended with,
you know what kills me and I have no idea.
Seven.
Evidently it wasn't killing me,
so I was exaggerating.
I'm already fucking bitching in 2015 that's the heat.
Hey,
can you shut off the fucking eight please?
Yeah.
Can you shut up?
You shut off the heat please.
Thank you.
What does that sound?
I liked this.
Something about the echo.
I feel like I'm in a locker room.
It's fun.
It's fun for me.
And this is my podcast.
Hey,
you want a podcast without screaming?
Why don't you go fucking record one?
Sorry.
He got looks could kill.
You know what year you got to get out.
I got fucking add.
I start looking at you.
You gotta get the Fuck Outta here.
So I can do the fucking podcast.
Either grab a microphone or fucking paid it.
Jesus Christ.
I'm watching the end of the cowboys.
He had,
fuck,
let's just go with this city.
You know,
I love whenever a fucking NFL team wins a playoff game and then they cut to the
owners box and it's always like 12 fat white guys in j.
Crew pullover sweaters
or I'll fucking excited.
Woo.
You know,
you know they all got a fucking,
their assistants are all carry and forum.
Bring that fucking book.
She'll go over to the fucking yard if pieces,
shit,
maybe I'll actually tip you.
You work working for free some day.
You're going to work your way up in this jog your shower facility.
Okay?
And they go down to the fucking,
where do you park a fucking boat down a yacht.
Not done on that.
Down the fucking docs,
right?
You get down here,
okay.
They tell their wives that they got some whatever the fuck they say.
And then they go down there,
they got this side piece,
you know,
some fucking chick from Switzerland got her hair combed over and it face like
Aaliyah.
That chick from that movie with the rabbit that was a cartoon.
But talk to the fucking guy who looked like Burt young,
who framed Roger Rabbit there.
Right.
And what are they do?
Ah,
they fucking break it out.
The chicks just sit there.
This site.
All right.
Doing blow.
They're not gonna want to fuck.
And they all are again looking at Jesus.
Look at a guy in the red sweater that's all stress eating.
You know why that guy in the red sweater was that fat?
Not Cause he's gluttonous.
Cause he had to deal with Jerry Jones wanting to draft fucking Johnny Manzel and
he had a fucking talk him out of it,
you know?
And then he just had ice cream and short ribs for the rest of the fucking year
after he dodged that bullet.
So anyways,
anyways,
let me shut off the fucking TV cause this is going to be too God damn
distracting.
Um,
by the way,
how many fucking football games are professional football players going to watch
where they see a fucking jerk off,
fumble the ball and then the defensive play a rather than just fallen on the
fucking thing.
He's got to pick it up and try to be a God damn star.
And what happens?
Either you don't pick it up at fucking squirts away or you're fucking get it
slapped out of your hands.
Unbelievable.
Anyways,
listen,
congratulations to the Dallas cowboys and to their fans and you know what to
Tony Romo,
cause God knows he woulda got blamed for that entire fucking loss all day.
That guy,
man,
I don't know what it is about him.
You know he got,
Oh fuck the turtles got the smarts,
man.
That's what the fuck it is.
I remember one time a long time ago I had a ranch,
but for my fucking divorce,
you want to talk about big day fucked Dallas used to see when I played this
fucking Twat,
right?
God Damn Bitch sitting on the fucking porch all day.
Why don't you cut up the vegetables,
put them in a pile of shit.
She wouldn't do it.
You.
I tried.
Sweet talking to mark.
Shut the fuck up.
Lemme finish the story.
This is my story.
This is my fucking state.
That fucking Tony Romo.
Let me tell you right now.
He got a look in his eye.
Lakia pheasant,
but smells rat.
You know what I'm saying?
Little stupid southern expression.
Yeah.
I swear to God that boy,
that boy would fuck a cow.
He saw a road runner cone up to a goddamn snake balls.
And that's true too.
You can put that right.
So anyways,
Damon fucking with this guy for so goddamn long.
He said like a million fucking offensive coordinators.
The problem is,
is what?
What's his face?
Jerry Jones is an owner.
Okay.
He's,
he's got leaner.
You ever see a quarterback's got little happy feet in the pocket dancing around
or what we do door to door.
He can't feel the rush,
but he knows it's coming.
Got a bad feeling about this one man.
Right.
He's just fucking sit in there like that dude and platoon rather than plant his
fucking feet,
checking down the fucking receivers.
Right.
Like I would do if I was tall and had talent anyways.
He's got happy feet as a fucking owner.
Anybody come down the fucking pipe that's done anything in fucking football
that's gotten a little disco ball hanging over it.
He fucky he can't get enough of it.
He could not get enough of it if he would just relax and let coaches coach and
the players play.
Okay.
Maybe slow down that elevator ride down to the fucking field.
I think Dallas would be a lot further down the road.
Okay.
You kind of,
you got to stop blaming your step son,
Tony Romo,
whatever.
Anyways,
congratulations to the Dallas cowboys,
to their fans and to that officiating crew that decided somewhere about four and
a half minutes to go like,
Hey,
what do you say?
Dallas wins this game.
Huh?
You got it like that on three but he brick bump.
How the fuck was that?
Not passing a ferrets guy.
He's running down the field like he's out of gas in the middle of nowhere,
flagging down a fucking car that's coming from the other direction.
Clear cut.
Case of fucking pass interference.
They don't.
They pick up the flag,
they pick it up.
The Dallas gets the fucking ball and there's more passive.
Ferris,
they don't pick up that flag.
I don't know.
I'm not saying it was fixed.
I would never say that.
I'm just saying it not with bay.
I'm a football,
but I just feel that there was a a,
you know,
it just wasn't,
come on.
Can you let the players when the fucking game,
I don't know.
What the fuck are you going to do anyways,
me and Paul Versey went round and fucking round this week about some sports
shit.
This will,
this is what,
this is the kind of guy when you listened to the Paul Versey effect,
the first effect podcast.
This is,
this is the level of intellect of this man.
I know he's going to get pissed at me.
I always do this cause then he trashes me on his podcast.
So here we go.
This is my side of the argument.
This is like,
listen to your parents argue through podcasting.
He fucking text me.
He said,
I think Cam Newton's going to have a big day today talking about when they're
playing the Arizona cardinals.
All right.
And this is the deal,
Paul verse,
he said Cam Newton was going to be a beast in the NFL.
Classic Paul Versey pick,
he picks this fucking guy who nobody's ever heard of.
Just like an uh,
12th round pick.
I mean practically off the fucking board.
And he just saw something in this guy.
I don't know what it was.
I don't know if it was the national championship and the Heisman trophy.
I don't know what tipped him off to the fact that he thought that this guy was
going to be a good player.
But Paul for z,
he sees things and this is what he would
say.
Well,
you know a lot,
a lot of fucking Heisman trophy winners don't pan out.
No easy.
Eish um,
anyways,
why don't you pick the second rounder?
Who's going to pan out
instead of hitching your,
your fucking wagon to this guy who's got his God damn ear staple to the side of
his fucking head.
All right.
So when,
anyways,
the nerve of me,
the way I look to criticize,
that guy looks like a superman,
right?
Anyways,
so I put on the fucking game and lo and behold,
the fucking Arizona cardinals,
they got a third string quarterback in there.
May God bless him,
but the guy through a screen pass and he fell down.
He look like me after a couple of beers.
Right?
Of course he's going to have a big fucking day.
Okay.
I know Arizona has a good defense.
All right.
Carolina fans fucking relax.
But when the opposing team's fucking Qb is falling down because he threw the
football,
you got to know there's going to be a lot of three and outs.
At which point Arizona's defense is going to tire out.
At which point Kalorama Caroline is going to have their way with them
and I'll tell you,
yeah,
she don't flip while week.
Um,
anyways,
I didn't actually watch a lot of,
I didn't watch a lot of sports,
but a verse,
he was driving me up the,
this is what,
this is what he did.
Granny.
He was fucking boozing it up last night,
but he fucking texted me and he's,
and know I trashed him about how he said that Babe Ruth is the greatest fucking
baseball player of all time,
which is absolutely fucking ridiculous and fuck all you baseball historians.
Okay?
Who are going to take out your reams and reams of fucking stats.
All right.
Is He is the fucking news.
I was just thinking what's his face in a,
in a,
what the fuck does not desperado what's it called?
Reservoir dogs.
Here's the news.
Looks like,
say a fucking hot car loan up there.
Um,
Chris Penn,
one of my favorites of all time.
This man,
this man who did his time,
he did it like a man.
It's just going to disappear
out of the fucking blue,
um,
to rip us off fucker.
And I talked my way out of it and I don't remember what the fuck I was just
saying.
Okay.
Oh Jesus Christ.
The fuck was I oversee.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Our key if all you fucking historians,
okay,
if your guy played when only white guys were allowed to play,
take 30% of those stats and his rock says turn it up sideways and shelve it
straight up
cause they don't fucking count.
Okay,
they don't fucking count
Babe Ruth fucking guys getting shit faced.
Bang and hawkers the night before the game.
Then he goes out,
throws a no hitter and hits for fucking home runs in the same game though.
That's like a beer league.
You know what I mean?
Okay,
give me a fucking break.
Don't you think it's weird that that guy played a hundred fucking years ago and
since he played,
there's never been another guy who could even remotely come close to doing that
to winning 20 games in a season and hitting 50 fucking home runs.
Bo Jackson
couldn't even do that and that guy is arguably a hall of fame athlete in two
different professional sports.
He couldn't even fucking do that.
You put them on the mound,
he would've got fucking shelter.
Gimme a fucking brick is another thing too.
I don't know if you guys have noticed this shit,
but once they let quote unquote the rest of everybody play,
did you notice what happened to the white population and everything but hockey?
It fucking plummeted.
Plummeted.
All right,
but when Babe Ruth played those fucking guys stayed in the league.
You had me playing fucking shortstop.
Hey,
no bad I Shane,
he's now batter.
Listen,
I'm not saying Babe Ruth wouldn't hit fucking six.
I'll give him 600 home runs.
Okay?
I'm not giving them over 700 I'm not fucking doing it.
Okay.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
He maybe could have taken Marianna Rivera deep,
but not every fucking time.
Jesus fucking Christ.
Give me a fucking break.
What a standup comedy was only white guys.
You know Richard Pryor,
Bill Cosby,
fucking day.
Eddie Murphy,
just all of those guys.
All of them out the fucking window.
Gimme a fucking,
it's the stupidest fucking argument I've ever heard in my fucking life.
And then to act like when you actually let everybody fucking play that the
competition isn't way more intense,
way more fucking intense.
And to sit there and say like,
dude,
the guys on base percentage shut the fuck up.
Shut the,
I didn't want to.
I don't,
I don't even want to fucking hear,
dude.
I'll tell you.
And that goes for everybody.
I'm not just picking on white guys here.
Fucking fuck wilt Chamberlain's hundred points in a game.
All right?
I Find Koby Bryant scoring over 80 points like two,
three fucking years ago was way more impressive than scoring a hundred points.
You know Dunkin on Bob Cousy,
not saying that he's not a fucking hall of Famer,
but I'm just saying,
come on,
give me a fucking break.
Ah,
Jesus.
I'm on a fucking tie right here.
And you also kills me is first he calls me up.
He goes,
Yo.
Yannis Pappas.
I don't know if you guys ever seen him.
He's absolutely fucking hilarious.
Okay.
He said,
Yannis Pappas is destroying your Babe Ruth argument right now you're getting
killed by Yannis Pappas,
right?
Which is fucking hilarious to me.
It's like,
Paul,
how am I getting killed?
I'm not there to fucking,
I'm not there to hear it.
I'm not there to defend myself.
This guy's out there.
He's punching at the air.
Okay.
This is the thing about a character like Paul Versey and Yannis Pappas,
alright?
These fresh faced a little kids,
they were born in the late seventies,
early fucking eighties and they don't know a fucking thing that happened before
the first Bush administration.
They now no shit.
They're the video game generation.
That Robin one app to some fucking porn site.
They grew up with a screen in their face.
Okay?
I'm telling you,
go out to one of this show,
see the look in their eye twitching up there.
Um,
this is what I was saying at first,
whenever verse,
he starts to get annoying me and I know it's his age.
I just say,
Paul,
why don't you do me a favor?
Why don't you go over there and go get yourself a malt and sit down and think
about what you said.
Okay.
And I actually texted him,
told them to do that.
And I said,
while you're at it,
why don't you go fucking by Yannis Pappas?
One,
two.
And if either one of you are listening to this clip the next time I am in New
York,
are you fucking cancer out here?
Okay,
we'll all go out.
We'll have a couple,
two or three and I will listen to your fucking argument.
I want you to explain to me how a man who never had to face the Pedro Martinez
back then,
the Marianna Rivera,
the Josh Gibbs,
all of those guys off the fucking table.
Jesus Christ.
It's like a fucking five on three.
The whole God damn game.
You scored a goal.
Oh my God,
that's impressive.
The fucking guy.
He pitched no hitters and hit 50 home runs.
I mean,
give me a fucking break.
He's a fat fuck.
That's what kills me.
You'll get no idea,
dude is fucking hand eye coordination.
Oh my God.
Get the fuck Outta here.
Jesus Christ.
I mean,
look,
look at the fucking 1920s
they didn't even know how to have sound in a movie yet
and then when they did,
everybody's like,
man,
why I Yada.
That was acting.
If people got awards for that.
Okay.
He played baseball during that fucking time.
Let me tell you something.
If you played baseball when you're fucking card,
your baseball card was in a cigar box.
Go Fuck Yourself,
okay?
I'm not saying that you couldn't play today.
Okay?
But take 30% of waste that's turn them up sideways and shove them up.
You fucking candy as cause I don't want to fucking hear it.
All right.
Paul Versey talking about his hand eye coordination.
Pullovers he's also the fucking guy who told me Seabiscuit was an unbelievable
athlete.
A fucking horse.
And you know why you said that?
Because somebody got an ESPN.
Paul,
you got to get on this podcast because I'm actually getting guilty.
I'm fucking trash and you so bad,
but I'm not for the simple fact that you said somebody was killing me when I
wasn't even there to be killed.
Who knows?
Yanis might kill me.
He might.
You know if he's got that ethnic name,
who the fool the fuck knows.
He knows how to make some fucking buckle voc by fucking hand.
Maybe he knows some shit about baseball.
I would love to have either one of you fresh faced kids convinced me how without
a doubt,
Babe Ruth is the greatest baseball player both fucking time.
And I'll tell you right now,
I don't want her to fucking word about those stats.
Jesus Christ
well could play a fucking basketball if he didn't let black people at
basketball.
There'd be like three people in the league.
Yes,
dude,
I gotta tell you crazy leg Johnson's back in the forties.
He's caught on at 20 points.
Oh God.
All right.
Uh,
I know,
I know I fucking beat it to death,
but I just had to make the point.
Speaking of which,
speaking of sports,
draft kings,
everybody,
little advertising here,
I'm going to have kings.com millionaires being made all
seasonLong@draftkings.com America's favorite one week fantasy football site one
week fantasy means no season long commitments playing whenever.
Yeah.
Juan got a player who's hurt.
No problem.
Quit your crying.
Alright.
Injuries won't deal.
Won't derail you.
Uh,
your shot at victory,
but cause it's like a new season every week so you're never stuck with the same
players.
Pick your God damn team in minutes and you could be on your way to winning huge
amounts of cash this season.
One listener turned 10 bucks into five grand,
another turn,
$2 into 10 grand.
Another guy edit his fucking marriage because he picked bet too much money.
Any lost
bet responsibly people and a new millionaire has been crowd nearly every week.
This season,
it graph kinks.com you could be next.
Imagine winning $1 million 500 grand after cash in one day.
Just playing fantasy football@draftkingsdotcomcalledtheactionhedgedraftkings.com
now and use the Promo code defense,
Yeah,
there's no c in that word.
Okay.
To play free and the $10 million fantasy football world championships.
Tell me you don't want to win that thing.
draftkings.com bigger events,
bigger winners,
bigger millionaires.
Enter defense now@draftkings.com draftkings.com once again,
that is draft kings.com oh look who's back.
Everybody beyond these me undies,
no more sweaty balls.
Boop,
boop,
boop me undies.
Biondi you could wear him down at the mall.
You fucking balls or hug real snake,
rural,
snug.
You walking up to ladies and they give you a hug.
Oh no more fucking sweaty bowls were some God damn me undies.
Oh yeah.
Get yourself some me undies but move,
oh no more athletes foot on your taint.
Alright.
[inaudible] 90%.
That's the percent of your life that you're going to be in your underwear there.
Unless you're Matthew mcconaughey and it's probably 10%.
Um,
and that underwear gets old fast.
You know that feeling of putting on old saggy underwear,
you know,
if your underwear quits,
you balls are going to quit and then you gotta go to work.
And what are they going to give you half?
They're going to give you another nickel an hour and tell you to sit down and
shut your face.
You need to know the feeling of victory.
And that feeling is great.
Fitting underwear that grabs you balls.
Let them know who's boss,
but let them also know that hey,
you're in for a nice ride.
It's two times softer than cotton,
but you guys know that.
Can you do that math in your head?
You need to know about me.
Undies me undies.
Biondi is,
is the most comfortable underwear you'll ever wear.
And it's insane how good they make you feel.
You're gonna walk down the street.
God dammit.
I feel good.
Woo.
They fit perfectly.
They don't ride up on you and they literally pull moisture away from your skin.
See a stakes stay cool.
Roast,
personalize.
Pick one.
Oh,
I'm supposed to.
I'm supposed to pick one here.
I actually wore a pair.
They're very nice.
Slightly a feminist,
but very nice.
I have mine on right now.
Do I?
Let me see.
No,
I don't.
Maybe that's why I'm so grumpy.
I bet if I had me undies,
I think Babe Ruth was the greatest player of all time.
Let's see.
I can't even tell you how great I feel when I'm staying cool and comfortable
down there all day.
I'll just tell you why that put them on.
They feel good.
They know right up my ass.
They hold my balls.
Nice sand.
I feel like I'm nicer to my wife.
How's that?
Was that personal enough?
Uh,
they have cool stars for both men and women and they all look great.
Oh,
they got it for women to me,
Hyundai's me undies.
No more clear me clam.
Um,
check out the photos yourself.
Me undies,
dotcom.
This quality would typically retail for two times the me on the price.
Okay?
If that's what you say,
no retail middleman means more.
Same as to you here,
I'll make it easy.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash burr and get 20% off your first order and free
shipping.
Save even more.
When you buy a pack of them,
they guarantee that you're going to be happy or you get your first pair for
free,
but they guarantee you're going to be happy with them.
Or your first pair is free.
But what if I bought a package?
Should I get another package?
All I can tell you is this people,
it's the beginning of the year.
All right guys,
come on.
You know,
even wearing your underwear forever.
Order some me undies.
Set yourself up for the year,
right?
Set your balls up for the year when they arrive.
Throw out your old once,
right?
Or wash him and give him to a brave homeless person and that's it.
All right.
Just go to [inaudible] dot com slash burn does that,
what the fuck it was?
I don't know what it is.
Anyways,
dollar shave club.
Everybody's last one.
I'll read here and then I'll get back to the podcast.
Can summer tell me when raised has got so damn expensive.
Yeah,
I can.
My whole fucking life.
It's been brutal.
A brutal rip off.
I'd been bitching about this since I started shaving back in the late eighties
anyways,
have I been asleep for 20 years?
I was in a store the other day and one pack of razors is now 20 bucks.
One pack.
That's crazy,
but hey,
sometimes they give you a free gift when you buy.
They're overpriced razors,
which is actually just a big punch in your fucking Dick.
Don't get beat up by the ridiculous razor prices.
Everybody get your shave gear where I get mine from.
Dollar Shave club.com for a few bucks.
Dollar Shave club.com delivers amazing razors and other great grooming supplies
right to your doorstep.
Can you see what I'm doing here?
People,
you got your me undies,
you get dollar shave club blades sent right to your fucking door.
What do you do?
You're going to shave your balls and put on the me undies.
It's going to be an unbelievable year.
Anyways,
here's how it works.
They send me the handle for free and every month they sent me my replacement
blades.
It's one less thing to worry about.
You can get deliveries every month,
every other month.
However the hell you want to do.
What?
They got lots of growing a grooming supplies too.
You know,
I love their one wipe Charlies.
Okay.
Uh,
why pay 20 bucks for a razor when you can get a fantastic shave for dollar shave
club from dollar shave club.com for a fraction of the price.
Stop getting smacked around by high raising prices.
I and you got to stand there away from the open the case.
This is a layup people dollar shave club.com raises are great and they're are a
fraction of the price.
Trust me,
you wish you'd done it a lot sooner.
Don't be a dumb ass.
Shave smarter.
Go to dollar shave club.com/bur bur that's dollar shave club.
Calm Slash Bird dollar shave club.com/bear.
All right.
Okay.
What the hell are we?
Let's get back to the podcast here.
Um,
all right.
Couple of things.
Uh,
I got to give a shout out to Stuart Scott.
Everybody,
man,
that guy,
uh,
one of the absolute legends of ESPN and watching that guy over the years as he
was fighting cancer,
uh,
just the way he went after it.
Man,
I really,
I mean,
I hope I never get it,
but if I ever do,
I hope I go at it the way that guy did it because,
uh,
that guy went out like a man.
That's all I'm going to say,
Stuart.
Scott going to miss you.
Um,
anyways,
and then I got some good news is a nick Depaulo,
Nick Depaulo,
a comedian that everybody should be,
everybody should know.
And every time they make those dumb fucking lists,
okay,
who's happening?
Who's now?
Who's this?
Who's that comedy?
Nick Depaulo should be on that fucking list.
I don't care how short that list is.
This guy,
he's a comic's comic and I'm actually excited if you've never heard of the guy,
um,
because you're going to get to discover the guy.
Um,
and I can give you like one of the best comics in the fucking country that not
enough people know about.
Nick Depalo has a brand new special out.
Uh,
I'm going to send you the link and all of that type of stuff.
We'll have that up on the podcast page and if you'd like to Google and search
him,
uh,
it's nick and then Depaulo is Dui and then space capital p a.
O.
L.
Nick Depaulo.
Uh,
absolutely fucking fearless.
And uh,
I did a tour with them a long time ago.
I told this story when I did nick and rd show a long time ago.
I did.
Um,
I had done the,
uh,
the Montreal comedy festival and the Montreal Comedy Festival.
Ha.
Um,
just for laughs is like huge up in Canada,
but you know,
people are starting,
get to know him down here,
but they had no idea who they were like 10 years ago when I went on this fucking
tour and um,
it was a sick taught tools.
Nick Depalo,
me,
Greg Geraldo,
rest his soul.
Uh,
Tom,
Papa,
Gary Gulman,
who else was on it?
I mean it was just,
it was just to kill a bunch of comics.
All great guys,
everybody having a good time.
And uh,
I used to watch nick when nick would go out there.
All of a sudden he's like,
his chin were dropped down to his chest and he wants to be looking through his
eyebrows and he would just be going back and forth looking through the crowd all
the way from stage,
right.
Slowly all the way to stage left stage left slowly back,
all the way over to stage.
Right.
I used to watch them do this every fucking night as he's telling these killer
jokes.
I'm like,
what the fuck is he doing?
What he's backstage is his head is,
he's,
you know,
he's got level flight here.
He goes out there,
he's knows down what the fuck is going on.
Right.
And I finally realized what it was because of material he did,
inevitably somebody was going to scream out at him.
So what he was doing was he was ducking down,
he was shielding his face,
his eyes from the stage light so he could see who said what.
So he could tear him a new fucking asshole,
I think I said on already.
So he was like a security camera,
just go and back and forth.
He's one of my favorite comics of all time and he's a great fucking guy.
Um,
so anyways,
when I,
when I do the Patrice O'Neal benefit next month,
I'm going to try to get him on and he's out here.
I know we did Joe Rogan's,
he did Adam Corollas and uh,
I think he did Jay Morris podcast to a,
was trying to set something up with me,
but he was all,
it was all backed up or whatever.
It just didn't work out between us.
So that sucks for me,
uh,
and my podcast and my listeners,
but I promise you I'm going to get him on probably in the next month.
I got to make it happen.
Um,
if as it would be an honor to have him on,
he's just fucking awesome.
So anyways,
moving on.
Um,
all right,
well I went to another Rosebowl everybody and I think I'm just now starting to
recover.
First of all,
what a fucking game.
I um,
just like the rose bowls are already unbelievable,
but to add that whole playoff fucking atmosphere to it was just insane.
And uh,
this year being and all the guys we got over there,
we were so fucking organized this year.
We,
we had,
we had fucking everything.
We had fucking everything,
food,
booze,
other stuff.
Jason Law had put on a display of tailgate cooking that it was,
he had a career year.
That's what we was saying.
He had a breakout.
It was just fucking on.
It was the best breakfast sandwich I ever had.
Then he made these ribs that were unbelievable.
Then we went to the game and at the end of the game it was freezing out by then
and we were smart as how smart we were.
We up quarter would and one of the grills we turn into just like a firepit and
everybody else who's waiting for the traffic,
every ball,
these people will come in and gathering around our little fire going,
you guys are smart.
Oh this is really smart.
What I left out is we brought everything except fire.
We forgot to bring a lighter.
They were bringing the grills and they were bringing the charcoal.
So I assumed that they were going to bring the fucking lighter.
And I brought the Lennar every year.
So I guess that one was one was on me.
I don't know what,
but other than that it was a,
uh,
it was another amazing time.
And um,
it was fucking hilarious.
We basically,
we get into the game,
got in on time because it's a fucking playoff game.
Right.
And there was so many people getting tickets that I couldn't get four together.
I got two and two,
so we were like couple rows,
two,
three rows in front of a Bart,
nick and La head.
And we're sitting there,
you know,
and I'm pretty,
I'm not as bad as I was last year,
but I was fucking,
uh,
I was feeling no plane.
All right.
I was definitely more than dehydrated at that point.
And all of a sudden I see security walking out with Jason Law head and there's
no,
Joe Botnick in Jay is looking at over at me with his hands,
like up like what the fuck?
And he's yelling at me and I'm going,
Jay Jay where they take it and I'm in like,
I'm in the middle of this fucking row.
There's like 30 people on one side,
30 and the other,
this old school stadium,
right.
Total fucking fire hazard.
Right.
I'm like,
Jay,
where are you?
Go Jay.
And he's fucking yell at me.
I can't hear.
And that Jay whisking them out so fast.
There's nothing I could do.
Other than that,
I just keep going with Jay j
plus looking at me like,
what the fuck turns out?
Uh,
I don't know.
Bart.
Nick was outside.
He was in the stadium,
but outside the stands,
I guess he had sat down or something and nodded off and when he came to there
was like fucking 20 cops surrounded him because he's such a big guy.
I thought they were like,
they were like,
whether this guy starts swinging,
we're fucked.
And they went down there and they told,
I guess they looked at his ticket and they went up to get Jason.
That's what they did and they said,
we got to,
he's been overserved,
which is the understatement for all of us for 2015 and a la had,
to his credit,
the only thing he did better than cooking was talk his way out of that.
He just kept going.
I come on,
look at the guy,
he,
he's,
he's a teddy bear.
He's like,
he's not,
he's not hurting anybody.
He's going to go up to and sit down.
He's going to be any of that.
He's at,
he just kept saying he's a teddy bear and Joe was just looking at,
hey teddy bear and next thing you know they fucking let them in fucking law.
Had the politician gets him to his seat,
he sits in his seat and then promptly fucking passes out and some lady behind
law head goes,
hey,
you're going to have to get him outta here.
And Jay just at him and said,
hey,
come on.
He's not her name,
but he's a teddy bear.
Okay,
listen.
And she fucking job back at him.
And Jay was just like,
listen,
if I tell you what,
if you will just watch the game,
you're not even going to see them.
Okay.
I mean,
I can wake him up if you want me to.
I'll wake him up.
I don't think you're gonna like it,
but I can't wake him up.
And people just started laughing and it was over and we had a wonderful time.
I'm seeing two of the top college football programs play each other.
It's a hell of a game through two and a half quarters.
And then,
uh,
Oregon.
I got to give a shout out to the ducks just for shutting up the Fsu band that I
didn't have to hear it,
that,
that fucking Tomahawk Chop again.
And I,
I,
dude,
I fucking called it that band knows three songs,
they know the school song,
they play something else and then everything else is
hello
the whole fucking game.
And um,
it was,
I mean,
I don't know,
I would like to see a little bit of a closer game,
but uh,
I really enjoyed,
uh,
the fact that they shut that band up.
Nothing against Fsu.
I actually really liked the Seminoles and I've always loved that program.
But um,
somewhere along the line that Tom lock chopped just fucking,
it would be like if at the Red Sox,
like,
you know,
awful.
It is when they sync.
Sweet Caroline,
just imagine a fake did that between every fucking inning.
I mean,
you'd want to kill yourself,
right?
If you want any sort of a human being.
And that includes being a red sox fan because I want to jump off the fucking
monster when I hear that fucking song.
Just once,
when you look at around him,
fucking women putting their head on the fucking guys shoulder,
it's just like,
uh Huh.
I Dunno.
Maybe I dunno.
Maybe I should be a little more positive about stash.
Shit like that.
I have no idea.
Um,
what else?
So it's a new year.
Do I have any
new year's resolutions?
Uh,
yeah.
I'm actually gonna try.
It's fucking hilarious with this podcast.
I'm going to try to lose my shit a little bit less.
Yeah.
Especially in when I drive.
I um,
you know what really,
I know this is an old comedy bit here,
but what really fucking bothers me.
This,
this is the,
um,
you know,
rather than just saying straight across the board,
I'm going to lose,
I'm going to,
I'm going to stop losing my shit when I drive.
I'm just picking,
picking moments.
Okay.
Like,
you know what I'm,
I'm,
I'm not going to flip out about anymore is when there's traffic on the highway
and that person in front of you leaves like a four card gap in front of them.
I'm just pausing right now for anybody who just wanted to go like,
oh,
I fucking hate that guy.
I know.
I fucking hate that guy too.
We all hate that fucking guy.
Unless you are that guy.
Is anybody that guy who listens to this podcast and for the sanity of the other
98% of the people on the planet,
can you please explain your fucking rationale?
100 I could lose my shit.
Can you please explain
your mindset as to why you feel that you have to leave that big of a gap?
You know,
and I was actually sitting behind this guy and I was starting to lose my shit
and go,
I'm not gonna lose my shit.
And I just sat in my head,
this guy it.
Rather than saying he's texting,
rather than saying he's a moron,
I just said this guy has gotten into a major accident and he broke his fucking
hip it,
and he doesn't want it to have,
but again,
so he's letting other people go,
okay,
just fucking,
and I hate that whole mentality.
Like why?
I mean,
what,
what are we actually saving in the end of the day?
I mean,
what's,
what's another car length?
You know what it is?
It's,
it's soothing.
Okay.
It's a,
it's a cold drink of water on a hot summer's day just to move another fucking
foot.
All right.
Can you know what,
that's what I do.
Isn't any anybody out there,
one of those fucking people.
Can you explain?
Please explain to me why you do that.
Maybe if I know why you do that,
then I can actually understand you more as a person and then I won't be beside
myself cause you don't see the world the way I do.
How about that?
Is that more mature?
And while we're at it,
people out here in la who ride bicycles in those clusters of 20 fucking people,
like you're having a bike race that nobody else wants.
Now I'm nobody else knows about.
Why do you feel that you're allowed to ride out in the road like that?
I've asked cops.
You're not allowed to do that or why do you ride side by side the two of you so
you can shoot the shit and you're slowing people down behind you.
I'm just asking,
don't you feel it's a little hypocritical if you want the fucking car to share
the road that you don't share the fucking road.
And while we're at it,
why are you dressed up with like sponsors on you?
Like anybody's paying you to ride that.
Fuck it.
That Jesus Christ.
It goes to temper.
All right,
let's get to some questions here for the week.
Um,
the rose bowl,
everybody.
Oh Dude,
I'll tell you right now,
if you're gonna pick a beer to start the day with,
I'm telling you,
Miller high life,
uh,
in,
in the,
you got to get it in the bottle.
Oh my God,
the sun's just coming up.
We've got the seven Oh four in the fucking morning.
It was freezing cold out.
There was a frost on the fairways.
I'm telling you guys,
you've got to fucking do this.
Okay?
You don't got to go to the Rose Bowl.
Fucking pick something,
okay.
That you and all you had dumb guy friends do,
are you and all your dumb fucking women friends.
Just,
you gotta have that one thing you do every year.
You got to have that.
I don't give a fuck what kind of responsibility you got out.
You got to have that one fucking thing.
So anyways,
we got to,
the frost was on the fucking fairways.
Okay?
I actually said this year when I got out,
I said,
hey guys,
guys,
got to go.
Take this in right here.
This is the best part of the tailgate.
It's the beginning.
Okay.
And this time tomorrow,
you're going to wish that this fucking moment,
actually no,
because he'd be too hung over.
Three days later,
when you get all the poison out of your system,
you're going to be fucking longing for that feeling.
Do we get out of that truck ear to ear,
fucking grins.
And then
Bart,
it's got this thing that he yells out to everybody to the entire lot.
Um,
I don't want to say what it is cause he yells,
it's so fucking loud.
And so far,
nobody's ever found our fucking tailgate,
which has been great because we make a spectacle of ourselves.
Um,
you got to do it.
So anyways,
the Rosebowl let's,
let's read this thing here.
Dear Billy football,
uh,
love the podcast she knew was special,
was nothing short of.
Amazing.
Thank you very much.
And thank you everybody who's been watching it,
rewatching it and telling other people to watch my new special you people are
all the same.
I'm sorry.
Jesus Christ.
I'm sorry you feel that way now.
Jesus bill.
Um,
I really appreciate it because a,
this one has been getting the best response and uh,
you know,
that makes me look good with the people I'm in business with over there and
Netflix.
So a,
you guys did me a solid.
I really appreciate it.
All right.
Um,
anyways.
Anyways,
here we go.
Anyway,
I had a question about your Rosebowl outing last weekend.
The game itself was great from that opening Oregon drive when Mary Yada,
I hope that's how you say his name.
I didn't,
it's two Heisman trophy winners.
I don't even know their fucking names.
I was so busy this year.
I was so hammered.
I even had a fucking program.
I had no idea.
Uh,
Mary Yada pitched it to the guy who somersaulted to the one yard line f and
later completed the two point conversion.
All that was great in the beginning,
uh,
to famous James flopping around fumbling for an Oregon touchdown late in the
third.
It was just a great game.
And I was thirdly jealous you were there.
You're obviously an Oregon ducks fan.
Uh,
my question is,
can you share with us a couple of your favorite moments from this year as
Roosevelt?
I kind of did that,
but there's probably some more.
I'm sure you had.
You in the goon squad.
You roll around with a gun in some funny situations of conflicts.
Ps,
I saw la head and part Nick in Boston for the all things comedy tour.
They were great guys and had the pleasure of sitting with Bart Nick at,
at the bar while Jay crushed it on stage.
Cool dudes.
I would love to drink and smoke stokes with you all some time.
Happy New Year and go fuck yourself.
You Apron wearing cont.
Uh,
that was a good one.
You passed it.
Um,
I think I've already told the,
uh,
the stories.
Yeah.
Throwing the football and the food.
I mean,
I dunno,
I was pretty sober,
but I was kind of a consistent,
leveled,
like blacked out.
Um,
okay.
I Dunno what,
what was it this year?
Just the whole fucking thing,
you know,
it was cool.
I was watching a father with his two sons and he was playing automatic Qb,
it teaching his kid the cornerback to get inside,
you know,
inside the receiver and a watching the big brother,
older brother fucking rivalry reminded me when I was a kid,
I sat there smiling,
drinking a beer,
probably look like a pedophile,
but I was actually thinking nothing but clean stuff.
Everybody looks like a pedophile now.
Um,
I dunno,
I gotta be honest with you the whole fucking days that God damn blur.
I remember most of the game I did.
I passed out a little bit in the first quarter for about a minute and a half
football time.
And then in the second quarter for about a minute and a half.
But,
uh,
other than that,
you know,
I s crushed waters for the rest of the fucking game.
I didn't have any beers afterwards because I had to drive and that's by then,
you know,
we stayed there till like eight 30,
nine o'clock at night.
So by then I haven't drank and like eight hours.
So I'm actually so sober,
I'm fucking hung over at that point.
Um,
so anyways,
uh,
Australian beaches bill.
Okay.
You talk about sharks and how they eat people constantly.
Is this going to keep you out of the water in Australia?
Ah,
you know what?
I love to say yes,
but I know if we have time,
my wife loves the ocean and um,
okay.
I gotta be honest with me.
I've never seen beaches like in Australia.
Last time I was there,
um,
which was two years ago,
this past October,
I was in Sydney and we talk,
we took a walk along the coastline and um,
and it was really rough waters and stuff,
but it was so fucking beautiful.
The only thing that stopped me was it was freezing cold out and the rough water
and I'm fucking terrified,
you know?
Yeah.
He's swimming in an ocean.
It's fucking alive.
Okay.
You swim in a pool,
there's nothing in there that can eat you.
And then also like,
there's no like,
undercurrent,
rip tide and all of that shit.
You know,
the ocean just doesn't itself doesn't decide that it wants to kill you.
Um,
yeah.
Well I go into it.
Yeah,
probably,
uh,
but no more than up to my waist.
And then I'll go back and I'll be freaking out that there's something fucking
swimming along there.
Um,
I do have to tell you,
since flying helicopters,
you can't believe what the fuck is out there just off the shore.
Um,
everything from like,
you know,
a group of porpoises jumping out of the fucking water,
which is cool to see.
And then you'll just see some big fucking thing by itself.
And you're like,
was that a shark?
Is that a whale?
What the fuck is that?
And you'll look like diagonally up like I dunno,
but a half a mile and there's a bunch of people sitting on surfboards waiting to
fucking catch a wave.
And uh,
I am,
I'm all set on that.
I'm all fucking set on that.
Um,
so anyways,
uh,
baking,
hey,
Jeez,
I'm fucking terror through these goddamn questions.
Oh No,
we got 46 minutes in.
Okay.
Plus I get some of the topics I can talk about.
Anyways,
baking bill,
I'm a 34 year old husband and father of a two year old boy I work had in our
family is doing well.
The hard work does take a toll.
And at the end of the day,
I had a heart.
I have a hard time winding down because work is always racing through my mind.
Hearing about you baking gave me the idea to try the same.
Ah,
Jesus.
Look what I'm doing.
The men in this country,
because another guy got to go buy an apron.
Uh,
don't even listen to these fucking assholes.
And one of the coolest things you can do is go out in the kitchen and make a
fucking killer.
God damned meal.
I swear to God we gave we,
we applauded.
Jason lie ahead more than we did those fucking teams.
The level of this guy was cooking.
All right.
I guess it's more mainly shit cause it's,
I don't know,
an open flame,
all of that type of shit,
but whatever do put on a fucking apron,
make it God damn pine pants,
Syrah,
fucking pork chop and then talk to me anyways at night.
Now after my kid goes to bed and my wife and I are hanging out,
I'll make a bread or a pie every night.
Dude,
you're going to be a house.
He goes,
I'm getting really particular about my techniques now and take pride in the
little things.
It's very zen.
Absolutely.
A one in five or six baking sessions.
I'll take a small hit off a joint and it's a perfect evening.
Thanks for exposing me to the idea and laughing at yourself from people on
Twitter.
Make comics about you being some type of Sally.
I gotta be honest with you.
That shit always makes me laugh.
Anybody calls me twinkle toes.
There was Sally that is always fucking made me laugh.
I don't give a fuck.
Uh,
and he says anyways,
it beats getting one of those small Japanese rock gardens from my desk.
Thanks.
And Go fuck yourself.
Yeah,
that's great man.
I would just be careful about making pies and bread every day.
You'll be,
you'll be,
you'll be a fucking house.
But,
um,
I dunno man.
I'm actually going to try to learn some vegetarian main courses so I can offset
everything else that I'm learning how to do.
Like I wanna learn how to make a fucking,
uh,
Sunday gravy.
Um,
cause I already know how to make pasta,
homemade pasta and I'm going to get a Ravioli maker and I'm going to do
something like that or make some Rigatoni Briga Falken Antony over there and I'm
going to a,
I want to make a Sunday gravy or something like that,
which I'm dying to do,
although I'm kind of afraid of canned tomatoes because I know then they don't
taste good and they're all so they're really bad for you.
And,
uh,
all I have,
I have two tomato plants out in my front yard and uh,
you know
what their yield,
I fucking eat.
I don't jar any of those things,
but I'm always just like a closet fucking Italian here because I actually want
to get a decent number of tomato plants out of my front yard and then just
fucking,
you know,
as they become right.
Obviously pick them.
And then I was going to,
you know,
skin the fucking things and then push them into a jar and then jar and then have
tomatoes,
my sauce all fucking year.
That's what I want to do.
Rather than getting these fucking tomatoes had been in Cannes for years and God
knows what they do here,
you know,
you hear Shit right?
So anyways,
that,
congratulations sir.
It's a great thing to do.
And any young people out there,
all right.
Men and women,
women cooking as a lost fucking art.
I don't know why you guys ever stopped doing it.
Nothing will shut your guy up quicker than making them a great God damn mail
here.
Eat it and go fuck yourself.
It's over.
He's going to have that in his head.
This is not new information.
Women knew that a long time ago.
Then somewhere along the line when they started growing out there fucking snatch
air when they quit using deodorant,
burning their bras,
that whole fucking thing.
Uh,
you know,
they,
they forgot some good things like,
hey,
you know,
make the guy a fucking sandwich every once in a while,
watch him shut the fuck up.
They just won't do it.
But anyways,
guys telling you,
telling you right now,
all right,
telling you if I could fucking cook the way I cook now back when I was a single
fucking man,
I just know what it would have been over.
One of my big regrets in life,
I didn't learn how to make a pike rest until I was in a committed relationship.
God dammit.
What an asshole.
Uh,
girlfriend says,
girlfriends keep sex tape from previous relationship.
Everybody
see where this one's going?
Okay.
Oh,
this is a heads.
This one has,
oh,
Jesus written all over it.
Hey Bill,
I've been listening for the past three years.
I love the podcast.
Especially when you freak out and throw tantrums and call yourself up by name.
He says in parentheses all really bill.
Yeah,
I guess I do that.
Those are the best ones,
but I have a situation.
I got a situation that might be of interest to you.
My girlfriend of almost a year has a sex tape.
Uh,
my girlfriend of almost a year has a sex tape with,
with her previous boyfriend.
What?
In the past she was very insecure in week,
very impressionable.
I believe this is why she was ever talked into such a thing,
but maybe I don't give her enough credit.
Okay.
I can accept that.
She made one in her past.
Her experiences made her who she is.
Oh,
Jesus.
However,
she made the decision to keep this tape.
Anyways,
after the fact,
she says,
I like keeping things that remind me of people and moments that made me smile.
Even if they were mistakes and didn't work out.
Oh,
go fuck yourself.
Yeah,
dude,
why don't you try this same thing?
Why don't you try this same thing?
Oh my God.
What a fuck.
You know,
I got to plug it up,
almost stopping a plotter for that fucking line.
She also says that she wants to watch this tape as she gets older because she
will want to remember when she had a great body.
You said,
I kind of manipulated her into showing me this tape.
What though?
By telling her that I think it's hot and that it might turn me on.
She had only been shy about mentioning it,
mentioning it in the past,
kind of teasing,
but maybe she was just afraid of my reaction and was testing how I was reacting.
All right.
This is fear,
sir.
My fear is
that your girlfriend is a freak and she keeps meeting guys that are not
relationship guys,
so now that she's met you,
you know this is our own little fucking freak thing that she kind of keeps it in
that I'm worried that she's going to be doing shit and this guy is going to be
doing stuff to her that you have not done or even thought about doing.
Okay.
In other words,
I'm waiting for you.
I'm worried you're going to see a load on her face.
All right there.
That's my concern.
All right.
When I saw it,
I felt so repulsed.
It was the unsexy as thing I've ever seen.
All right.
Well,
well but the other way she was traumatized too.
Very traumatized.
So I kept my cool and competencies around before I head to head home.
Wait a minute.
So she pops this thing in.
You guys are both horrified
and did she start crying and then you shut it off?
It had to be like,
well you know I'll call you tomorrow.
I don't mean to laugh sir,
but this is I,
this is supposed to be a funny podcast so I got to keep the comedy coming here.
Oh my God.
Jesus Christ.
All right,
here we go.
Now she says,
okay,
did I act weird and that she's sorry that she hurt me but she doesn't apologize
about keeping this tape,
nor have I asked it to.
I think it's beside the point.
If she only does it to appease me.
Oh she,
she has to get rid of it cause she wants to is what you're saying?
Am I reacting out of a bruised,
macho ego?
I could never imagine keeping a sex tape from another relationship while I'm in
a new one.
Yeah.
I don't even keep the normal photos tagged on my Facebook.
What's your advice?
And maybe Nia can add her opinion too,
since she might think I'm being possessive or judgmental.
It would mean a lot to get your advice.
Thanks a lot.
And Go fuck yourself.
Well,
she's upstairs.
He's heard of Marty driving a fucking nuts.
Um,
no,
dude,
you're not.
You're not.
This is completely fucked up.
It's fucked up in,
it's weird
that she would keep that fucking tape.
It's fucking weird dude.
Like,
come on man.
Can you imagine saying that to your girlfriend?
Hey,
I got a sex tape from the last woman I used to hook up with,
but uh,
I just keep it,
you know,
cause I like to keep things from my past that,
remind me of things that I've done,
even if they were my mistakes.
But you know,
with the end of the day,
it just kinda makes me smile.
Okay.
She would do,
would just be dead silence.
So you would just,
she would be,
what the fuck did you just say?
And then as start at the top,
she
tell you to shut the fuck up as she proceeded to break up with you.
Because to me that's like,
okay,
it's,
it's bizarre.
This is,
this isn't fair because I'm reading this.
I didn't hear how she said it.
I don't know anything about her,
but that's fucking bizarre.
That's not,
it's just not cool.
MMM.
It'd be bad enough if you somehow found it,
but at least she had the decency to keep it a secret.
But the fact that she even fucking tells you about it then it ain't like he's
just makes me smile.
You know?
Like,
like she has a fucking quilter grandmother made.
Yeah.
I don't know,
Dude.
I don't think,
I think you gotta be like,
look,
you need to get fucking get rid of that thing.
Okay.
That's fucked up.
Yeah.
Okay.
And,
and,
and fuck,
you're fragile state.
Okay.
Fuck your state.
What about my state?
All right.
Get rid of the fucking thick.
That's what I would say without all the fucks in the anger.
I know,
Dude.
That's fucking weird.
All right,
next one.
Oh wait.
You know what?
Let me,
let me read the last bit of advertising and then I'll,
I'll knock this one out.
No bullshit.
Some more,
and that'll be a podcast for the week.
Oh for fuck sakes.
Here we go.
What is going on here?
Where the fuck is it?
Come on bill.
You can do it.
Live reads.
All right.
Going to have kings.
We did that.
Me undies.
Mandy's dollar shave club.
We did that.
All right,
the last two.
Oh,
one of our old favorite stamps.com everybody.
One of the great resolutions you could make for the new year,
maximize every minute and every dial for your small business.
I know an easy way to do it with that company right there.
stamps.com think about how much time you've wasted going to the post office
driving.
They're finding parking,
standing behind the old lady with the smelly hair.
stamps.com is the better way to get postage.
Just use what you already have,
your computer and your printer to get official us postage for any package or
letter a they need.
A mailman comes by and picks it up.
What could be easier with stamps.com everything you would do at the post office,
you can do right now from your desk at a fraction of the cost of one of those
expensive postage meters.
I've been using stamps.com for the last couple of years setting up my tour
posters.
I am a moron if I can figure out how to do this.
So can you,
all right?
You're already getting underwear shipped to your house.
You're already getting shaving cream and your blades sent your way.
Why?
I have to go to the w you're going to become a Gore phobic with the shit that
I'm selling to you here.
You know if we have to leave a damn house again right now,
use my last name burpee.
You are to get this special offer,
no risk trial plus a $110 bonus offer that includes a digital scale and up to
$55 free postage.
Don't wait.
Go to stamps.com before you do anything else,
click on the microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburraburthatstamps.com enter
paper.
All right.
Lastly,
but not leastly legal zoom,
everyone.
What's your New Year?
What's your top New Year's resolution?
Everybody,
if you're like me,
it's getting your life organized,
but where do you begin?
Wait a minute.
No,
I don't want to have road rage.
Why did they do that to me?
Stop saying what I think I'm going to sell your shit.
All right.
Anyways,
a great place to start is protecting your family and a great way to take control
of your family's future is to make a will.
I actually have to do that.
I have to do that or living trust.
That's where legal zoom can help.
There's no easier way to make sure your family is legally taken care of.
Getting your life organized also means taking control of your financial affairs,
so if you're thinking of starting a business or you,
you have one already legal zoom.com can help you for Jesus.
Sometimes I just get lost here.
Legal Zoom can help you form your business and provide
the support you need to run it successfully form and from look the exact same to
me for more for more than 10 years.
Legal Zoom has helped millions of people get the personalized attention they
need and if you'd like more help,
they can connect you with an independent attorney in most states,
but they are not a law form from this month.
You can save even more by entering burn in the referral box at checkout.
That's Promo Code [inaudible] B u are r.
Don't let another year passed you by before getting your life organized there
for Legal Zoom you can count on what for legal help you can count on for your
family or small business.
Go to legalzoom.com Promo Code Burger that once again,
that's legalzoom.com Promo Code Burr.
I have got to fucking do that this year
and I'm going to use legal zoom when I do it.
There you go.
There is he,
you don't have to write copy for me.
I'd fucking do it myself.
I do it myself.
All right.
22 year old hitting on 26 year old manager.
What the Fuck's wrong with that?
22 year old hitting on is 20 on 26 year old manager.
There's nothing wrong with it.
Hello Bill,
longtime listener here and I'm writing to you today for some advice.
I'm a 23 three year old man and currently have the hots for a 26 year old
manager.
Just a little background,
she's originally from Louisiana and is smoking hot.
I love her already.
She just moved here around a year ago and always complains to me about being
lonely because she does not know many people here in Cali.
Fuck toad.
Okay.
She's laying it right on the table for you.
What is she going to do?
Fucking throw her legs in the air.
First of all,
you said you're 22 now you're telling me you're 23 anyways.
She's always being extra nice to me like buying me,
buying lunches,
always checking up on me and staying a while to chat.
It gives me the eyes from time to time.
Where do you live in the,
you might be mistaking her southern house house puts hospitality cause he used
to some fucking cold east coast women.
The fuck are you looking at your fucking Douche bag?
Right.
And all of a sudden she comes up,
you all know Napkin.
Don't she wants to suck it.
Yeah.
Just make sure it's not that.
Anyways,
um,
me considering myself a pretty handsome guy,
I was thinking if I have a shot,
yeah.
Thinking if I have a shot or what,
come on guys,
I suck at reading.
You've got to proofread these things.
I was thinking if I have a shot or am I just over my head here?
No.
Yeah.
Not totally have a shot.
Just this new year's.
She was constantly complaining about,
she had no invitations to new years.
Dude,
this woman is throwing it at you.
So me making a joke,
since I also did not have any plans,
said,
hey,
maybe we should hang out and get and drinks of wine.
You think I can have a shot?
If so,
how would I go about hanging out at her place?
I live with my parents that Jesus or am I taking her kindness for flirting?
Oh,
Jesus do Jesus.
We've got to get you in the game.
Thanks again,
Bill.
Great seeing you at the White House.
Spare that did that.
All right.
Hey,
dope.
Do you know we've got to do it?
You know I'm going to do right now.
I'm gonna make you,
you.
I got to get you to stand up straight.
Okay.
Eat.
Don't have a say.
Maybe.
You know,
maybe we should if there's no baby.
Okay,
you got to tell her that.
Let's hang out.
Don't say it like that.
Say I don't get dumb pitch.
I'll say it like that.
Yeah.
Just tell him,
let's hang out.
Let's have some fucking wild.
Let's say,
what do you want to do?
I'll show you around town.
I'd say that.
They need a fucking friend,
Jesus Christ.
If I had been in a relationship this fucking long,
I would just fucking come up to her and just say,
listen,
I do wait.
She's your manager.
Who gives a fuck,
dude,
you're 23 have you fucked a manager yet?
You got to fuck one boss and see what that does to your fucking professional and
personal life.
You get,
you learn that lesson,
you'll be a better man because of it.
You just got to fucking,
she's already thrown it at you.
You got to tell her you going to hang up.
Then you got the fucking out too,
because she's your boss.
Be like,
hey,
we can't to get through fucking hot and heavy here because the whole business
thing,
right.
Plus she's three,
four years older than you.
You know what I mean?
I think she's just looking for somebody to fucking hang out with and uh,
give her a nice one.
You know what I'm saying?
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
Bill.
That was fucking,
that was very piggish.
That was very piggish.
But you're totally in the game.
Okay?
She's smoking hot.
She's got that southern accent.
This is fucking killing.
It's killing me right now that you're not banging her yet.
All right.
And you know what?
Who have a fucking fucking woman who is offended by saying that too?
That I said that.
All right.
Jesus Christ.
It could get that.
Could they fucking bitch anymore?
Good Lord.
Every fucking days on the Internet,
there's another article about what men are doing wrong.
I'm going to give women in general advice.
It stopped rolling your fucking eyes at me.
Okay.
You're getting makeup.
All of your eyebrows.
All right.
Listen to me.
Okay?
This is what you need to do.
Stop telling men that you don't give a fuck anymore about what they think.
Okay?
The mere fact that you taking the time to do that means you give a fuck.
Yeah.
Just,
just fucking
do your own shit.
You sick a guy's running shit.
Start Your own shit for the life of me.
I don't know why they don't go out and start their own shit more often.
Look,
look and look at the fucking woman,
I guess in my business.
Okay?
I can think of like three right now.
Who's fucking,
rather than sitting around udo good roles to women,
they sat down and wrote a fucking script and got the fucking thing made and now
they call him the shot.
That's what you do.
Actually,
man,
man or woman.
That's what the fuck you do.
But this whole fucking bullshit where you sit there and you say,
what's wrong with your life by criticizing the other sex,
all that.
Okay.
Uh,
my record is shit.
The bed or God is a feminist,
um,
picky.
The one I,
uh,
I just listened to it beginning of the podcast and heard that I did say June 5th
instead of January 5th.
So I'm sure you guys were all attacking me on Twitter now and joining,
making fun of me yet again this year.
A happy new year to everybody.
Go fuck yourselves.
I hope you have a wonderful week.
I'm nervous about the patriots playing the Ravens.
They got a hell of a defense.
And uh,
I dunno,
I don't like that game at all.
Don't like that game at all.
But we'll see what happens.
I'll talk to you guys next week.
Go Fuck Yourself.